vous parlez des cinémas puisque raphaël
mezrahi donc est au cinéma je vous le
dis le à rennes le 11 décembre à evreux
le 13 décembre au havre le 20 décembre
dans des cinémas le spectacle de raphaël
mezrahi vous avez dit vous avez déjà mis
un coup de pression à quelqu'un au
cinéma vous savez je suis pas de nature
bagarreuse ont comme vous en tout cas
alors je sais m'imposer mais d'une autre
manière
oui il ya cinq ans des joies un harry
potter je voyais un harry potter on
voyait un mec qu'on arrive à voir le
fait un des films harry potter c'est un
des derniers et je prends la séance la
première séance
10h30 au moins je suis sûr que personne
personne ne va vous embêter
je me place au milieu du cinéma en
milieu avoir une vue face entre hal et
là tu as un mec qui débarque et qui se
pose n'est vers moi comme ça et avec
c'est anna ce nom il me fous des coûts
l'horreur à longueur de journée on va
évidemment première et infusions alors
pour me faire entendre
laser là ils vous donnent une fois ci
bazar beaucoup de pression et où un
premier degré au deuxième degré je me
retourne comme si de rien n'était mais
dis-moi troisième degré je me lève gm
est qu tu va dégager immédiatement n'en
avais pas dit dégagé ce ne sont pas les
gâcher a pas dit dégagé les jetons tan
mai et la remise et de parts de bertoua
oui est ce qu est ce que monsieur vous
pourriez vous calmer s'il vous plaît
voilà là sûr que là je reconnais m'être
répond très bien
et au final je changeais de deux sièges
le m
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon sport préféré de l'année